[Music]
corrine elympios boyfriend is standing
by her side amid her bachelor in
paradise scandal check out Corinne
taking a stroll with her beau Jordan
Gill chin ski in LA on Saturday the pair
kept things casual in coordinating gray
and black athletic gear for a low-key
lunch date as et previously reported a
source close to Corinne says she was in
a relationship with Jordan before
signing on for season four of the ABC
show this mystery man of mine he's gonna
remain a mystery
how does he feel when you say you might
go on bachelor in paradise have you guys
talked about it it's so complicated
we're told the 24-year old reality star
didn't plan to hook up with anyone
during filming Corinne intended to stir
up drama for exposure Corinne and
Demario Jackson who is also involved in
the incident that shut down production
on the show have both lawyered up
according to their reps neither have
seen the footage of the incident in
question a source tells ETB
investigation into allegations of
misconduct on set is expected to wrap up
this week